on a là la même problématique de
féminisation au niveau du sport et
handicap
c'est à dire peu de femmes donc quand
vous êtes sportif de haut niveau ou pas
mais faut prendre des décisions dans la
vie vie professionnelle vie sportive vie
familiale et donc automatiquement il ya
tout un parcours qui est fait que
souvent les femmes ne reprennent pas
leur carrière sportive après les
naissances parce que mais voilà il faut
s'occuper des enfants il faut voilà il
ya une vie qui fait que mon travail il
faut il faut s'occuper de la maison il
faut s'occuper des enfants et bien
souvent qu'est ce qu'on va mettre de
côté je pense que c'est la vie sportive
moi j'ai une jeune fille aujourd'hui
elle avait un peu de temps donc c'est
une jeune fille que j'ai eue elle avait
10 12 ans à l'époque
donc on l'a toujours eue en tant que
pratiquant de sportive et elles servent
à sion c'était le sport on en parlait de
sarbacane donc on parle de boccia elle
était vraiment voilà c'est ça sa passion
est en fait elle est en structure
du côté de limoges est en fait la
structure ne comprenait pas qu'une fille
puisse aller faire du sport
elle était passionnée de ça c'était son
leitmotiv
c'était son coût ouais c'est aujourd'hui
je vais faire du sport enfin c'était
voilà est en fait la structure a
toujours dit mais toi en tant que fille
ça serait plutôt faire atelier cuisine
faire atelier nains mais je je sers
atelier couture est en fête et quand
elle me disait ça mais je lui disais
mais c'est parce que tu es la seule
fille à faire sur ces temps d'activités
sportives tu es la seule fille à me dit
oui je suis la seule fille donc en fait
il ya vraiment quand même on pousse on
pousse pas forcément la jeune fille
allait faire du sport donc ça c'est déjà
faut avoir quand même
soit vous êtes dans une famille de
sportifs et du coup ça va suivre la
logique familiale donc on va aller faire
du sport mais en situation de handicap
on est quand même confronté à des
problématiques géographique
si vous voulez faire de la sarbacane
mais cette jeune fille elle est de
montmorillon voyez enfin faut venir
s'entraîner sur poitiers faut quand même
avoir l'appui familial quand même
derrière les finalement il a fallu du
temps pour faire bouger un peu les
choses pour pour faire évoluer pour
faire changer les idées de certaines
personnes aussi nous on est on a des
compétences
on peut les les transmettre on peut les
proposer qu'on peut avoir qu on arrive à
s'organiser pour donner du temps
pour garder nos vies en fait nos vies la
fois professionnelles familiales
finalement on arrive à faire ça il ya
beaucoup de femmes qu'ils le font
aujourd'hui
[Musique]